Right, what do you need
to know?
This is my boyfriend,
Jason.
He's great.
I mean his hair's
better longer but-
I'll go shirts. If that's-
Is that right?
So turns out we can't
have kids the fun way.
Which is, you know
it's absolutely,
completely,
totally, fine?
So what do we
do now?
A small piece
of us dies and
we just carry on
with whatever is left
Alright.
Well as long as we've
got a plan.
But we have a plan.
We're going to adopt
our own family.
And I thought right.
If we're going
to do this
we need to become
more you know,
grown up.
Start using bay leaves
in cooking
even though they
don't taste of anything
and everyone
knows it.
You're talking like an
American again
you know I hate it
when you do that.
But then sort
of realized
you never really
feel grown up
or ready enough for
the big stuff do you?
You just have to
sort of, do it anyway?
Or you run
out of time.
So that's what
we're doing.
We're doing it anyway.
Let's see what
happens, shall we?